[موسيقى]
تتنفس هذه الارفف المزدحمه بالكتب النادره
التاريخ الاسلامي والعلوم الشرعيه وشتى
المجالات العلميه المختلفه والتي يحتضنها
المسجد النبوي ويعود تاريخ البعض منها الى
عده قرون عدد الكتب يزيد عن 7000 كتاب
جميعها مرقمنه يستطيع ان يستفيد منها
الباحث هو الزائر اما عن طريق الاطلاع او
عن طريق
الرقمنه بحيث انه يستطيع ان يحصل على نسخه
من هذه الكتاب اقدم هذه الكتب عمره ما
يقارب 200 سنه يحرص الباحثون وزوار المسجد
النبوي على التردد على هذه المكتبه للتزود
بالمعلومات والمراجع الموثوقه لاستكمال
ابحاثهم والتزود بالمعرفه ممكن تحصل في
هذه الاداره على كتب وتجدها هنا غير
موجوده في المكتبات الاخرى لان اسمها
النادره وهي الان هنا محفوظه معتنى بها
ولها برامج
ترميم وبرامج تعقيم
في الجانب الاخر قسم خاص بالمخطوطات
الاسلاميه القديمه والثمينه التي يرجع
تاريخها الى القرن السادس الهجري ويقصد
بالمخطوطات الاسلاميه التراث الاسلامي
المكتوب بخط اليد وقد عنيه المسلمون
بالمخطوطات عنايه كبيره لكونها السبيل
الوحيده للحفاظ على ما انتجه العقل
الاسلامي
في اداره المخطوطات اكثر من 4000 مخطوط
اصلي واكثر من 500 مصحف مخطوط اصلي يعتنى
فيها وتعرض لي الزوار والباحثين وطلاب
العلم يشهدوا المسجد النبوي منذ مطلع شهر
رمضان اعدادا مليونيه بعد التشغيل بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود مقدمه كافه
الخدمات بمختلف اشكالها للتسهيل على
المصلين والزوار من المسجد النبوي سلطان
السلمي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات